[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
history repeats itself I think is the
theme for today's first story former
attorney general Jeff Sessions who is an
even more former Alabama senator is set
to announce today and may have already
announced by the time you watch this
show or listen to the show that he is
going to run for his old US Senate seat
according to a Republican official
familiar with the plan which could very
much cause some interesting dynamics
with Donald Trump and Trump's influence
that he has over his supporters sessions
of course was the Republican senator
from Alabama before becoming Donald
Trump's Attorney General when sessions
became Trump's attorney general he
became immediately embroiled in
controversy when he actually correctly
recused himself as Attorney General from
anything related to Russia this led to a
special election in Alabama between Roy
Moore and Doug Jones Doug Jones the
Democrat narrowly defeating Roy Moore
despite Roy Moore being accused of
serial sex assault on numerous women
including some who were quite young and
now sessions wants to go back and I mean
listen this is gonna create a lot of
interesting dynamics between Trump and
the Alabama Republicans between sessions
and Roy Moore between Republicans and
sessions who may not be pleased with him
the trumpet Republicans may not be
pleased that sessions even recused
himself at all I don't even know what
the most interesting element of this
entire thing is going to be yeah we
always talk about what trump
administration officials can do once
they leave office and it's sort of
depends like if they completely
embarrass themselves in their role in
the Trump administration like Sean
Spicer did for example your options are
kind of limited like maybe you can write
a book and go on Dancing with the Stars
but it's kind of hard to re-enter
politics would be taken seriously
I think Jeff Sessions though because he
didn't really lose his integrity because
he did the right thing by recusing
himself he can still make a political
comeback but then again you think this
is Alabama
this is one of the most conservative
states in the country this is one of the
most Trump states in the country can he
do it there and I think that's an open
question what a lot of people are saying
is it's going to come down to who Trump
puts his weight behind and reportedly
you would imagine that says Jeff
Sessions would have talked to Trump
before announcing this the reports are
that they have not spoken about Jeff
Sessions plan so the question will be
does Donald Trump say hey it's time to
go for my former attorney general
despite the fact that Donald Trump
pushed him out and didn't like a lot of
the things that he did but on the other
hand Roy Moore is running again so is
Trump going to say vote for again go and
vote vote for the serial accused child's
hold on accused serial sex assault or
Roy Moore who Trump begrudgingly ended
up supporting in the special election
after supporting someone else in the
Republican primary for that special
election I don't know but political
analysts who know Alabama Pat are saying
that it really could come down to who
Trump supports I don't think it's
entirely outside the realm of
possibility that Trump will back Jeff
Sessions even though they had this big
fallout and it was totally public sure
because Trump also backed Mitt Romney
and Romney's Utah Senate race and they
you know I've been back going back and
forth for a long time yeah I think this
could be a three-way race in the primary
because there could be like Jeff
Sessions there could be Roy Moore and
then like a third maybe unknown who is
backed by Trump who's just like a
classic Trump estai and the three of
them could maybe split the vote and I
don't know maybe potentially cause Roy
Moore to win or like who knows in that
case who would win and I believe that
there is in other words I think that
Jeff Sessions entering the race he is
entering a race that already has more
than one candidate I believe that there
already is Roy Moore and someone else I
don't know who it is and it doesn't seem
like it's someone particularly known to
either one of us but we'll see what
develops there we will see what Donald
Trump does about it kind of good news
from Italy Italy has been having some
anti-vaccine sort of say is is a form of
an education problem although often it's
much more than that
but Italian school students starting
next year in every grade are going to be
required to study climate change and
sustainability and the idea is that
Italy wants to be a world
leader on environmental education the
Education Minister Lorenzo Durham auntie
is saying that there will be 33 hours a
year in school curricula to study issues
linked to climate change they will be
built into civics classes they will have
an environmentalist footprint and the
idea is to create well-educated citizens
of the world that will be part of
solutions rather than problems I think
that this is absolutely great Pat and I
think that in the u.s. we obviously
should be doing this but we should be
going further I've been talking about
for years that in the u.s. we need to
start teaching critical thinking early
we need to start teaching epistemology
early I would like to see philosophy
taught early and certainly considering
climate science as an integral part of
any serious education if you are
supposed to come out of school
understanding the paramount and foremost
issues affecting our planet today why
wouldn't you be studying this so good
for Italy for doing it yeah it makes all
the sense in the world especially
because climate change is an existential
threat other topics that we teach in
classes like you know maybe history or
foreign languages or English those are
important subjects and of course we
should learn about them but they're not
nearly as serious as something like
climate changes and students are
primarily the people who are gonna have
to take the burden of climate change
they're gonna have to fix the problems
with early we're leaving behind and I
think by teaching climate change in
schools and like prevention and
mitigation you can inspire the next
generation to come up with some
innovative ideas like there's that what
is he like 20 years old that kid who
came up with this way to get rid of the
plastic garbage patch in the ocean you
have a Greta Thornburg who's making
headlines
you know big in the news right now so I
think this is this is something that
other countries should be doing as well
in that in the United States as well too
if here in the United States there was a
proposal made to mandate that climate
science must be taught at every grade
level like can you can you even imagine
what would happen within our education
system what Republicans would be doing
like it's it's inconceivable the degree
to which they would say this is the
atrocity perpetrated of this of the of
the decade by Democrats and by the way
how sad is it that it's Democrats the
would be saying that this is a good idea
it would have to be done by the states
and of course the blue states that would
do that it wouldn't be something that we
could do nationwide I don't think and
you know Italy you know me being a front
and center and this fight against
climate change kind of debunked this
idea that scientists are just pushing
climate change so they can get grant
money here in the United States like
that's the conspiracy theory that
Republicans often push well if that's
the case then how come there's so much
universal consensus on this issue how
come it's not just scientists in the US
who buy into climate change it's also
people in Italy in Germany and Africa
and Asia like as everyone just bought
and paid for here on this issue of
course yeah the reason that Botswana and
scientists are accepting the science on
climate change is because they want to
get all of that Botswana
money to fund incredibly lavish
lifestyles that makes absolutely perfect
sense ya know it's crazy and you know
motive alone does not a conspiracy make
and often that is all conspiracists have
is some hypothetical motive in this case
the motive doesn't even make sense we
don't even have the motive for
justifying why there would be this
conspiracy to collude around you know
allegedly false climate science which of
course we know it to be just the real
science and that's what it is so good
for Italy we'll see if other countries
implement this and I would say we'll see
if the u.s. does it but obviously we
won't but as pat says maybe there will
be blue states where they will say we as
a matter of course we are going to teach
climate science the kids and we should
also do critical thinking and we should
do epistemology but it's you know you
got to start chipping away maybe there's
some low-hanging fruit and we can make
some progress we've talked about the
criminalization of poverty and
homelessness and one place where the
City Council is taking action is Las
Vegas which has approved a ban that will
make it illegal to camp or sleep on the
streets in certain parts of the city of
course this will criminalize
homelessness in many cases this passed
five to two after a bunch of hours of
public comment at the Las Vegas City
Council it will make it a misdemeanor to
rest sleep or lodge in the Las Vegas
downtown district and some residue
areas if there are shelter beds
available so that's a good thing because
it does if it's not illegal if shelters
are full
that creates some impetus to make sure
that there are shelter beds available
but still you are criminalizing being
poor and being homeless violators will
be fined up to a thousand dollars or
jailed for up to six months we know that
oftentimes even if there is a bed
available in a shelter conditions are
not always safe conditions are not
always appropriate they are not always
what we would like them to be so we've
seen this in San Francisco in different
ways Pat I don't deny for a second that
there is a problem in Vegas with
homelessness on the streets I go to
Vegas twice a year for a conference when
you walk around the strip area there's
no question that there are areas where
one might not feel particularly safe
although I've never witnessed any
violence or anything like that it's
people who are down on their luck and
looking to to acquire some money or just
for a place to sleep but this is a theme
that we've been following yeah and they
say that they don't want to make this
penalty oriented like there will be a
law on the books that you could face
jail time or a fine if you're sleeping
on the streets yeah but hopefully that's
just a last resort problem with that is
if you have individual police officers
enforcing the law and maybe they come
across a repeat offender someone who you
know sleeps on the street day after day
maybe they would put that into their own
hands and try to charge the person with
with sleeping on the streets maybe
arrest them and you know that doesn't
help the situation how is that supposed
to help them reintegrate back into
society so I don't think this is the
right move at all to criminalize this
and it seems like such a natural thing
right I mean like this is just sort of
normal body functions we eat we sleep
you know I think that it is
criminalizing something that's just so
humans be able to like get rest and if
you have nowhere to go I mean any maybe
you just don't want to go to a shelter
for whatever reason that maybe there are
many luminaries right yeah the other
thing about this is this is going to
actually make solving if we believe that
the idea is to end homelessness right
which it should be but maybe it's not
actually this is not going to help do it
because in particular people who are
already homeless it's harder for them to
find jobs it's harder for them to get
back
on their feet financially and get a
place to live where they can rent and if
you have a thousand dollar fine
potentially hitting you because you're
sleeping on the street that won't make
it easier to find a job and it certainly
won't make it easier to make rent
payments so it's one of these things
where we are criminalizing even though
we claim we want to solve a problem that
we make worse via the policy which is
completely backwards in San Francisco
experienced that as well yeah I would
imagine that if you have some like big
shot in Las Vegas who's visiting and
he's wearing a $5,000 suit and he maybe
just had too much to drink and he passed
out outside of the bar and I'm gonna
strip he's not gonna get charged with
anything I think it's purely just the
homeless population who are susceptible
to getting criminal charges and you know
that's that's the double standard that
we have in my country I read a comment I
don't know if it was like the president
of the City Council or the mayor of Las
Vegas who said something like we know
that there are some flaws in this and
we're gonna work to fix them like yeah
the main flaw is it's not going to solve
the problem in any way and it risks
actually making it worse that's sort of
the primary flaw that I would find that
this may actually do the opposite of
what you wanted to do yeah I mean maybe
I'm being cynical here but I feel like
the primary reason they're doing this is
just so that rich folks don't have to
see poor people on the street as they
walk by them I mean you know maybe that
is too cynical but that I got when I
went to Las Vegas a couple months ago
and I noticed that you can't you can't
just walk across the street you have to
go up an escalator over bridge and then
down the escalator it's across the
street and that of course just is you
know not very pedestrian friendly and
the reason that you do that is the favor
car traffic and who's more likely to be
driving around the city versus walking
around the city it's the rich folks
absolutely and a lot I don't know if you
noticed but there's a very popular spot
for what we generally speaking call
panhandling which are those overpasses
and they are areas where because of how
the city is designed at least in the
strip area we're talking about to be
deferential to car traffic and less so
to pedestrian traffic although you could
argue that not having to wait for a
cross at the street is sort of
pedestrian friendly it's just that it
can end up taking forever because you've
got to go up and down escalators and
across bridges that is a very popular
spot for the panhandling that it seems
like they're trying to deal with and
I'll be totally honest it's not the most
delightful scenery but I've never felt
threatened by the people the many people
that I've seen panhandling in those
overpasses I don't know if you did and
it's just it's not the problem that it
is often made out to be we could just
deal with the homelessness rather than
putting in criminal penalties because it
just quite frankly doesn't seem that
urgent to me yeah I wasn't threatened by
the panhandlers I didn't find them
particularly aggressive but what annoyed
me is how it took like half an hour to
walk how cross country yeah yeah I mean
that that's just horrible
okay see they pass something like that
yeah that is not an annoyance of Las
Vegas but one that we could call a first
world problem I think admittedly that
does it for today new show tomorrow and
a new bonus show I hope you will join us
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]